okay hi so as Michael said I'm Ryan I'm
have this company in gradiant space
except on Monday I started working at
Epic Games which I don't really talk
about cuz I've only been there for like
three days but yeah so my background my
research background was really in
computer graphics with kind of like a
minor in HCI so I built lots of user
interface systems but uh more on the
graphics side so building like tools for
doing 3d designing you know making
shapes and computers let's usually how I
describe what I did so I worked on
procedural shape modeling I worked a
little bit on geometry processing
algorithms I built lots of 3d design
tools I built this this is like a 3d
drawing tool the one up there was a tool
called shape shop for like moving around
implicit surfaces and kind of making
neat stuff but mostly people if they're
familiar with what I've done know of
this software mesh mixer that I made
which was an Autodesk product eventually
sort of so if you're not familiar with
mesh mixer I want to seem you are it's
we kind of described it as a Swiss Army
knife for 3d meshes so if you have a
triangle mesh from like a 3d scan and
you made an academy one to do things to
that mesh and there's not a lot of tools
for doing that and so we built this tool
I started in my PhD and we just kind of
added to it over time so it does all
sorts of things those 3d scanned cleanup
mesh repair I'm printing utility stuff
3d sculpting it has this drag-and-drop
3d modeling I'll show you examples of
all of these things as I go through so
like I said it started during my PhD I
did this at first which was sort of a
demo for a paper that we released online
in 2009 and people just started using it
in 2011 autodesk acquired it by 2016 it
had been downloaded over a million times
and had thousands of people using it
every day this is a picture that someone
from autodesk posted on twitter
this is downloads in one month in 2017
so really all over the world people use
this software even though it's not
localized anywhere except in english
japanese and chinese there's no other
languages but people all in these you
know like in the very far reaches of
russia you know are downloading
meshmixer and making stuff with it
which was sort of more surprising
because it was never really like a real
product like if you called up autodesk
support and were like hey i'm using this
product of yours meshmixer for the first
like six years of it light of its life
they'd be like what's meshmixer we've
never heard of it it was developed in
the research group by me and then a team
of me and another person there was no
sales or marketing there was not really
official support there is now but there
wasn't for most of its life and so this
was kind of fun for us I mean for we saw
it as a research experiment less than
not so much as developing a real product
it was really driven by like the users
of the product and like what they wanted
to do with it so when we started out
after I made the dragging and dropping
parts we added 3d sculpting and this is
very early I think in 2012 we did a
workshop with this organization girls
learning code in Toronto where these are
like teenage girls doing 3d sculpting
than they would 3d prints of things it
was kind of fun but then that once we
have the 3d sculpting then you know more
serious users came along and were like
we want to make this have you know a
needs this feature it needs this feature
and within a year we had like people
making stuff like this in it which we
would have never thought that was
possible once that started happening
then they started using it to clean up
3d scans and then 3d printing came along
and 3d printing year all those 3d
printing meshes and so we started adding
3d printing tools and so this was our
sort of most well-known tool is for
generating if you ever used like a
MakerBot you need these like support
structures that you have to break off so
the ones that come with the printer if
you try to print something like this
it's impossible you'll break it trying
to get the support off so we made this
like very sparse supports that it still
took like half an hour to get them all
off but you can actually do it and so
that was a very popular feature and then
from there we added all sorts of other
3d printing stuff and that's why there's
those people all over the world using it
like I said there was no support so the
users supported it which is always a
horrible thing to say about a product
and like all of the users did it but we
had really amazing things happen like
this was a Kickstarter there's a company
in Berkeley called honey Point 3d that
was like a 3d printing shop they ran a
Kickstarter to make tutorial videos
where they raised $14,000
and made this tutorial series that now I
think like 9000 people have bought now
there's videos all over the place on
lynda.com you can get meshmixer
tutorials for doing stuff and on youtube
if you go on YouTube it's kind of crazy
but this is actually evolved now when
you search this is thirty five thousand
results I don't I mean you know these
searches always come up with all sorts
of stuff but there's a ton of videos on
YouTube that people make meshmixer
tutorials and showing you how to use
features and stuff like that they submit
bug reports with videos on YouTube and
we started to find over the years like
more and more serious stuff so like it
started out as a lot of these videos
like this top video here is this guy
makers news who just tries out 3d
printers and he's like a video blogger
guy I guess but these are videos made by
dentists and like real dentists these
are dentists who have 3d printers in
their office and they do 3d printing
procedures or like dental procedures
using their 3d printers so like if you
go this guy 3d dentist he's got a whole
series of videos of using meshmixer to
do these dental procedures and they just
post them online like this is how you
let's see like this top one is if you
want to remove someone's tooth they make
this jig they use and stuff like that I
mean if these are long videos and
they're very like actually there's now
two dentists that teach they essentially
teach courses they teach like digital
dentistry courses that are basically
like a mesh mixer in a foreign labs
printer it's kind of crazy this is a
project from UNB where they do these
kind of tooth replacement surgeries
where they make these 3d printed jigs
they design them you know they take a
scan in your mouth they design this jig
this is a little I mean that I don't
want to describe it because you have to
think about it but like the top one
there is a jig where they're basically
cutting off the low parts person's lower
jaw and these are implant guides where
they're gonna put in screws and then
they're gonna implant a set of teeth but
you know I look I love these projects I
mean there's a ton of like maker
projects where people are doing fun
stuff with it but I love these projects
because they always for me are like when
I when someone would say like wasn't 3d
printing over you know that came it
happened it was on the top
the high perv it's over now but it's
like it's really not over all over the
world people are using these machines
these like consumer-level machines and
using 3d printers and using these kind
of weird design tools to do all sorts of
stuff so Toronto general in hospital in
Toronto is not unique anymore and that
they have a 3d printing lab in the
hospital this is now becoming a very
common thing that a hospital has a 3d
printing lab and what they use them for
so like this is just a print of
someone's CT scan and the surgeon will
look at that before a surgery just to
make sure that like their mental model
of what's going to be in there when they
open the person up is right and I've
been to conferences where you hear these
stories and you're just like oh my god
what's happening in these hospitals
we're like the surgeon was on the way to
the to the operating room and stopped
into the print lab and the print just
happened to finish in time and they look
at it and like oh that's not what I was
expecting and they put it back and go to
do the surgery right
but that's happening now that's like
that's the thing that happens these
other two here so these here this is a
print of someone's skull obviously what
they're doing here is they're preforming
these little metal it's hard to kind of
see but they're little metal grids that
they're gonna use during the surgery so
otherwise they have to do that on you
while you're cut open they have to form
those things on you which then you know
there's more risk of things going wrong
and the longer you're cut open and so
they can do it now unlike a 3d print
before those things happen so it's
actually not I mean it's not on the hype
core but this is really being done not
just experimentally I'm going to tell
you about two projects now basically for
the next chunk of the talk in more
detail two of these projects I just
think these projects are super cool and
they're gonna illustrate the rest of my
talk so this one is done by a lab at
University of Buffalo they have a kind
of experimental hospital where some
floors are a functioning hospital and
other floors are biomedical engineering
research lab and chip I need us there
his lab does this project I'm gonna tell
you about so I only my only involved in
this really is that I kind of give them
some advice on how to do stuff in rush
mixer but I'm gonna tell you about the
whole project because it's kind of
amazing so if you have like an aneurysm
and they want to do a minimally invasive
surgery what they do is they feed a
catheter which is basically a wire
and inside a tube up through your thigh
and they like steer it through your
blood vessels up into your brain up into
the aneurysm and then they fill it with
this platinum wire and so what that does
they fill the whole thing and that coil
causes the blood flow to reduce in there
so the aneurysm is based like a bubble
and if it pops bad things happen and so
that once the coils in there the blood
flow slows down in there and then it
clots and then it kind of fixes itself
so the problem is they have to get this
wire through all your blood vessels into
your brain which is really hard and if
like they obviously if they poke the
wrong place or something bad things
could happen so they have to practice to
get good at doing this and so they have
these simulators there it's kind of
funny they're almost like a video game I
got to use one and it's like it's
physical setup but like you're just kind
of turning this wire and steering it I
mean obviously when they're doing it
it's very serious but what it is also
I'll show you what the the whole thing
looks like but here this is the
simulator setup where basically this is
supposed to be like what's inside your
head the blood vessels that they have to
steer through or those are the hard ones
this is like where they feed it in up
the up the in your thigh and the
catheter goes up there and then they
have an x-ray setup so I'll show you on
the next slide but this is the you can
kind of see here the wire in there it's
just it is literally basically a little
wire it's good so a little tube and the
way the person does it so they stand
down here I mean they're standing down
by your knees right and they're looking
at a screen up here that's where your
head is right this is a big x-ray
machine and that's what the x-ray they
see up there and that's what they're
looking at so that's why I say it's kind
of like a video game here you see this
basically and you can kind of see the
wire I don't have a nice video of this
and you're kind of basically like steer
the wire through these blood vessels and
you what you can do is you can like push
and pull and turn it and then there's a
little trigger where you can kind of
cause it to bend at the end so I mean
obviously this is hard because this is
what you see right the blood vessels are
this complex 3d network but this is all
you see you see this 2d projection with
this kind of fuzzy overlapping so and I
mean
that when I say they want to practice it
they couldn't really practice it you
could practice on like standard models
of these things but the idea of just
like fabricating some like if they take
me in there and I'm like well we just
want to make my brain blood vessels in a
little plastic thing that we can
practice with I mean how would you do
that you couldn't do that before now
they can do it with 3d printers so they
make these vascular Fantom it's called
and this is the mesh mixer part now they
essentially starting from the scan they
like make that thing and it's like
conceptually it seems kind of
straightforward you have the scan you
pull out this geometry you make a mesh
and you 3d print that mesh this part
here is actually quite complicated of
how you do it so they have tutorials
essentially which they publishes
research papers so this is a paper I
can't remember the name of the
conference that had this at but
essentially it's a tutorial and it's
kind of for me it was a bit embarrassing
to read this paper because like this
there's a whole section of paper about
dealing with mesh errors these are
essentially my bugs like I made mistakes
so now they have to have sections of
their paper about how they compensate
for my mistakes yeah yeah so they
simplify a lot because you don't the the
catheter also doesn't go in the very
tiny blood vessels generally the I think
the aneurysms are mostly on the larger
blood vessels that you'd want to deal
with and so they so you see here from
here they removed a lot of the blood
vessels it's the same or maybe this
isn't the same model but they all those
little ones they take out that's part of
the process because they can only make
stuff at a certain scale the walls have
to be kind of thick enough there's a
whole aspect to this that I don't know
that much about which is to do with like
the pressures of the blood vessel in the
blood vessels and so that's another
factor it has to be somewhat realistic
material-wise but the net effect is they
can they can make these things they use
them so this is a person from a video
stratasys made who actually had the
surgery done in ER that's her brain
blood vessel she's holding that they
used and the video the doctor says like
it's a good thing we did this practice
because we in our initial plan we found
you know some problems and so it's a
good thing we have the system
and so I mean for me the interesting
thing here is like this
this printer existed long before they
did this project this wasn't really a
new thing but what they had been trying
to do is they've been trying to make
these complicated shapes using like
mechanical engineering CAD software for
many years they tried to do this and it
just hadn't worked it's too hard to make
these things so they we gave them like a
new tool and it the tool essentially
came out of this maker community of like
tools for you know teenage girls to do
3d sculpting and now they're using it to
do these brain surgery planning type
stuff which I think you know it's kind
of interesting and this is another
project I worked on this is the project
with university of toronto's i was much
more involved in this one so Matt righto
there at the critical making lab he kind
of drove this project and this one is
actually I mean you know in some ways
totally different use case but the
conceptual level is almost the same as
the previous project so we needed to
make legs essentially so if you lose a
limb here or if you're born without a
limb and you go to get a prosthetic what
you get is this quite fancy this is like
usually carbon-fiber sockets CNC milled
you get nice aluminum parts and stuff
like that if you are in Uganda what you
get is something more like this so this
is a hard plastic shell hard plastic
connectors and stuff like that the
standard this is the standard Red Cross
process for doing this so this is the
process that like Red Cross will give
you money to do is essentially all based
on plaster casts so they take a cast of
the limb they that's the negative then
they make a positive they use a this is
a pizza oven that they use to heat up
this sheet of this starts out as a flat
sheet of I think PVC plastic and then
this is a vacuum forming machine so the
plastic the positive there's on the end
here underneath and the vacuum form that
on top and then they kind of like grind
at it with dremel type tools and stuff
like that until they can attach it to
that plastic stem which is a standard
part so this works and works fine the
biggest problem with it is that
for instance when we were doing this in
Uganda the entire country that's 36
million people there was 12 prosthetists
which is not very many like Canada is a
similar number of people we've got way
more than 12 still not enough but a lot
more than 12 it takes them about a week
to make a leg waiting for all the
plaster to dry and doing the stuff they
need to do if you're a kid then you're
growing so then you need your legs
changing size so you need new ones all
the time so it's not really a problem of
like the technology we don't need like
higher tech prosthetics there we needed
just more of them just like a lot more
prosthetics the big project biggest
problem is access to care so the World
Health Organization estimates that
40,000 prosthetic technicians are needed
globally I can't remember 100% but I
think that's actually more than there
are right now globally so the idea that
we're gonna just generate tons more
prosthetic technicians
it's very quickly seems unlikely and so
you know the actually the hospital and
Uganda came to us and said like could we
use these new 3d printers to make these
hard plastic shells that we make now
with the pizza oven and the vacuum
forming right and you know we kind of I
mean I thought like obviously of course
we could why not it's just a hard
plastic shell but I mean it's more
complicated than that in practice I'll
tell you about it but essentially our
goal here in this whole project was to
develop this process for making these
things and the critical thing there was
that it's usable by the prosthetists not
by me like I can do it in rush mixer
well I could have prostitutes do it and
I mean ultimately the the actual
practical was to say it's not going to
take you a week it's gonna take a day so
you can come in get scanned and you'll
leave with a prosthetic that day that
was the goal so like I said you start
out we scan just a complicated we use
these off-the-shelf like this is a 3d
sense scanner but this essentially is
the same thing and they're like a
Microsoft connectors right it's not the
most accurate but also prosthetics are
not the most accurate and you have to
clean up the scan and stuff like that
and then the modeling process is not
that complicated you have this scan of a
limb we make this kind of plastic shell
around it you attach this connector at
the bottom and that's essentially a
prosthetic you attach the standard piece
to the bottom of there
in meshmixer we had all these tools that
we could kind of assemble into a
workflow for doing this this is a demo
video of me doing almost the entire
thing in you know 30 seconds I think is
playing it too or maybe Forex but
doesn't take very long essentially you
need to make that curve at the top the
right shape now this is me doing it so
this is completely wrong it's not what a
prosthetist would do and that's an
important thing actually that we learned
in this prod in this project you've
probably seen maybe even on like like
public media like other prosthetic
projects don't just make prosthetics
it's very dangerous you can really harm
someone by just making them a bad
prosthetic so it's very important that
actual prosthetists are involved and
that's kind of why we have to make the
thing usable by them we also did lots of
mechanical testing for the same reason I
just said you don't just want to put
these things on people without knowing
that they're gonna be safe and stuff
like that so they did this robotic
testing and like these are in strong
machines where they just physically
destroy it to see how strong it is and
then we went to Uganda so I went on the
first trip there's been quite a few
since then and basically we took all
this like high-tech stuff to these labs
well this was the first lab where
essentially I mean the most
sophisticated equipment here was the
pizza oven most of the stuff is hand
tools they're doing this all at hand
tools and we made prosthetic so this was
our first patient essentially Rosalyn
she was a six year old girl and this is
the leg we one of the processes they're
designed for her I printed on the
MakerBot we had a bigger printer but the
power kept going out so this was the
perfect size it just fit in the print
bed they put the leg on it and then she
could walk on this prosthetic and it fit
well we had another an older girl who
basically said she thought these fit
better than the ones we had they had
been making which wasn't our goal but we
were super excited that result right and
this became this company nine
technologies now which is a I guess the
website isn't on there was an nya tech
org so they did for clinical trials at
different sites in Uganda Tanzania in
Cambodia I was over 200 kids wearing
these prosthetic now and they're
currently
making a new version I'll talk about a
bit more which is currently being tested
at Sunnybrook Hospital it's the hospital
in Toronto and I think now they've done
a deployment of the new system in
Tanzania
so they improved the printing all sorts
of stuff they changed materials they
experimented with all the different
things and it got much better and so I
mean I've told you about some of these
different projects and I mean I really
love these projects and they really
nicely illustrate like the use of these
new printers and things like that this
new technology that's come about but
also I can look at these projects and
see that quite a few of them are kind of
stuck in a stage and I'm gonna talk
about that for the rest of the talk
about what the sort of problem is still
in this concept of like that you could
take this these new machines and this
new types of software we've made and
somehow provide that to people
in these new domains that's not actually
working that well yet I'm gonna you talk
about this one specifically so this
project now has been going on I think
since 2014 I mean it's amazing they do
with like brain surgery with these
things that would saves Pete literally
saves people's lives but they only do it
at the one Hospital in Buffalo and part
of the reason for that is this
complicated workflow I described before
so it's it's not it's sort of on the one
hand it's not that hard to do this but
on the other hand it's really hard right
like a technically sophisticated
computer science student can figure out
how to do this they have a lab there of
biomedical engineers who are now
essentially medical or meshmixer experts
and they're the ones who make these
things but not every hospital has a lab
of biomedical engineering students who
are experts of this who can make these
things and so you know what they would
like to have is a tool that would make
that easier and that doesn't exist yet
I'm gonna explain why that's not
happening yet so how do these projects
happen I look I've looked at these a lot
of these projects we saw a lot of them
with meshmixer
and there's a kind of almost life cycle
that they go through right and the first
thing that happens is they have a
workflow right someone figured out how
to use these tools and these machines to
produce this thing
from their inputs or whatever right and
so this is a nice slide I found I came
across at Autodesk so this person
Tatiana Samba Silva is from Autodesk
here in San Francisco it was I don't
think she's there anymore
but she made this offer called photo fly
which became one to 3d catch that's the
like if any of you ever use it was their
cell phone scanning app or you could
take pictures of something it would make
the 3d shape so they have a higher-end
version that Louise Leakey who's like a
very famous anthropologist I think was
using so this it's kind of fuzzy in the
pictures here but oh you can see over
there this was like a skull that they've
got somewhere in Africa and this they
want to do like a 3d reconstruction of
it right so this is their workflow you
can see there's arrows going backwards
it's very complicated I mean the app
makes some things seem really simple but
if you care about the science if you
care about like being able to take
measurements office precisely and stuff
like that you know you end up having to
go from this tool to this tool back to
this other tool and this is pretty
common I don't know if it how many of
you have ever liked how to solve a like
kind of real problem using these kind of
any of these CAD tools really you often
end up going between things and stuff
like that and so we call those workflows
and workflows are fine if you are like a
you have to do it but they're not fine
if it's kind of optional and that was
our thing we kind of came to realize is
that like a lot of the people who want
to do this stuff they're not engineers
they're not even they're not really
makers either they're not like tinker's
these are professionals like professions
like prosthetist or medical doctor and
they don't want to they don't want to
learn how to do this right like I showed
this video before I mean it doesn't look
that hard but if you don't know this
software if you didn't invent it like I
did then all these things that appear
are confusing like which thing I'm using
hotkeys here you don't even notice maybe
I'm changing like one slider and not the
other one right like learning how to do
this is a took takes a lot of time for
anyone you can be trained on it if you
can find someone to train you but like
if you are working prostitutes you're
busy making prosthetics and being
trained to learn some CAD tool is not
what you do a lot of these things
like I mention the dentistry ones the
way that actually happens in dentistry
where there's a lot of 3d printing
already being used so they hire a
technician who does it and then they
talk to the technician and there's all
this translation error I'm try
technicians are expensive and so then
there's all this friction and making
these things happen
so then often it doesn't happen so then
the next thing that tends to happen
after you have this workflow is people
start to think like oh maybe we could
make a plug in to one of these existing
tools right we did that in the
prosthetics project actually the first
version like when we went to Uganda we
this thing we called the wizard which
was like this separate as a browser
thing that could talk to meshmixer
so you could it would automatically
start the tool you needed and it was
better but it still didn't really work
you know so here this little text field
over here that's gonna set a parameter
of something that happens over there but
I mean if you you can maybe already see
the problems like what if I make a
mistake well this thing I mean you could
go back sometimes you couldn't always go
back and do didn't work that well what
if I accidentally over here click and
cancel out of something that's easy what
happens to these plugins is like you
have to learn too much still you still
have to essentially learn the host app
you have to learn how to like rotate
things and do all these stuff in that
app there's all this hidden state that's
confusing like like the undo problem and
really the host API is often don't have
very good API is there not I mean maybe
if it's open source you could go in and
change the source if you knew how to do
that but even that is a pretty tall
order
and the interfaces you can actually
build it usually not very good so we've
seen people try this and it's basically
doesn't seem like it's ever really
worked so then what you get to is like
oh we need to build our own tool and
that is I mean it's the hats happen at
every single time I've talked to people
of one of these projects is where they
get to is like we want to make a tool
that's like our workflow exactly this
step this step this step as hard because
every one of them is completely
different or it seems right if you talk
to them they're going to tell you it's
completely different I mean their own
tool building these tools from scratch
is a lot of work I mean meshmixer we
wouldn't work on it continuously but it
took us like seven years so when someone
would come and say like how hard would
it
be for me to build our own meshmixer
that just had these three tools it'd be
like well it's gonna take you a long
time and you're gonna need a PhD in
computer graphics maybe which is pretty
tall order and then the other problem is
a lot of these domains are small so like
this brain surgery thing I mean if you
truck go and try and like raise money to
build that it's tough because you can't
say like this is gonna be a billion
dollar industry prosthetics is not a
growth industry so it's really hard the
prosthetics companies there's there was
a sort of competitor prosthetics project
and they've already pivoted away from
making prosthetics because it's just not
big enough and that's why these tools
don't already exist and so what I the
sort of conclusion I came to is like we
need some sort of infrastructure for
doing this where it is customizable for
these workflows but you can make
interfaces for these non-experts and I
really like I kind of wanted to do that
with meshmixer but it's really hard to
go back once you've built all of this
stuff getting rid of it all so you can
just have three things becomes this huge
software engineering project and I mean
also there's like business problems like
Autodesk doesn't want to make hundreds
of small apps for different industries
or at least I can't speak for Autodesk
anymore but at the time no one wanted to
do that so I started this other company
gradient space and that was really my
plan was like figure out how to make it
possible for any developer to build a 3d
design tool so like not an expert
developer but just like someone who kind
of do can do decent coding how could
they make a 3d design tool and not like
a prototype one but like a functional
one that you then you could give it to a
doctor and the doctor could say like I
can basically use this except this bit
here and this bit here and you'd fix
that and then they'd be like okay now I
can make these brain surgery things that
was the kind of the hope and so I built
all this infrastructure for doing that
I've mentioned infrastructure before so
I built some open-source libraries this
geometry library this 3d printing
library and then this app framework
that's mostly what I'm gonna tell you
about these are all open-source with
commercial friendly licenses so I mean
they have to be if people are going to
make companies out of them and that's
important thing people often say like
wouldn't it just all be open source
open-source developers do this I mean
what the
dentist once is like a company they can
go to that's going to come to their
office and set everything up and give
them a training course that doesn't
really happen with open source it has to
be companies because you have to do all
this other work just to get the stuff
out there so open source isn't
completely work I'll just mention a bit
about the slicer because I know there's
people here that do fabrication stuff so
the slicer is all entirely open-source
there's lots of cool features and the
slicer in geometry library I write
tutorials on how to use them on the
gradient-based website so if you're
interested in that kind of stuff I won't
talk about anymore but you can find out
more there and happy to talk about it
afterwards I'm gonna talk about this
framework a little bit more so it was
called frame three sharp I started a C++
version and then I made a C sub C sharp
one so that's why it's called that so
this was meant to be like a design tool
app framework it's kind of what I called
it sort of like I don't even know if
people know what qt is anymore
maybe electron should I say like
electron but for 3d design apps
I don't know I'm old so I view I view I
was actually I initially had win32 there
and I know that most of you've never
used 1/32 so like the I wanted to like
be the standard library of all this
stuff you need right so all the standard
3d tools like those little XYZ axes
things you move stuff around gizmos new
islands I'm gonna show you examples of
these things built in like if you want
to undo and redo changes to 3d models
that should be in there supporting the
different places you want to have 3d
stuff so that's a lot of that is kind of
built already so the first thing I build
with it so then basically what I did is
I built some tools to make sure that it
was useful and working that helped kind
of guide the design so this is a VR app
sort of a weird angle or at least from
where I'm standing this is called
simplex this is basically like a simple
VR design tool but you can see it's got
like my manual interaction it's got kind
of a kind of heads-up display here so in
your head said this is you know right
kind of at a reasonable distance and
stuff like that
and so it has these kind of
many 3d shape manipulation tools I build
this other app cotangent which is a 3d
printing tool and it has some mesh
repair stuff and things like that so
these are both going to become
open-source now because I'm not because
I have a new job and I'm not going to
continue doing these apps of gradients
base I'll I'll just mention that they're
not open source yet but they will be but
the ones that were kind of for me more
exciting were two companies that I
worked with to build the apps on this
stuff so there's this company arch form
which is a dental 3d printed not they're
not 3d printed dental aligners companies
here in the Bay Area it's startup if you
know what Invisalign are they're kind of
trying to do stuff like in the in the
same direction as Invisalign and Nia fit
ortho VR sorry these are the names of
the product so this is the prosthetics
an eye technology so they made a new
version of their app based on this
framework actually too so we made a VR
version and a sort of desktop version so
this is a demo of the VR version play
automatically you don't think so
HTC gave us some funding and we made
this VR one so you you can see now this
is the sort of more domain-specific tool
so it's you know in some ways it's not
that different but like over here the UI
is just the exact tools they need you
know you can only do the certain things
at certain times this trim line in the
old one I was like painting the
triangles with a brush that's not what
they wanted they wanted like a curve
they could say and should it be exactly
like this
I mean tools that are intuitive for them
to nudge this curve around rather than
like a bunch of control points that they
would click and drag on you know I they
have to make this socket at the end they
want to be able to like tweak the socket
a little bit without having to go back
so this is when I say domain-specific
design tool now this is a as close as we
could get to like exactly what they
wanted and then it's built on this
framework so we can take that and put it
into a desktop app too so this they have
a desktop and mobile versions and it's
not like when I say the same they didn't
like cut and paste code from one to the
other this is like a the actual what
happens in here is like a library that
they can just we could use in both of
them and then
and this was like this is my best
example of exactly what I wanted to
happen so this is the dentistry app they
needed to like segment the teeth they
need to move the curves around and this
is the prosthetic sap where they need to
do this script it's the exact same tool
this never happens in CAD tools you
never have like a tool from fusion 360
being just like copied into inventor
because other completely different code
bases complete different architectures
you can't do that and so this was sort
of my goal is like you would have a
bunch of these tools there's kind of
building blocks you could kind of put
together with UI and you can make these
domain-specific design tools so that was
the premise you have this library you
would have this other thing now I'm just
going to tell you a bit more about how
it was built so it was built on top of a
game engine and this I think is for me
this was really interesting when I was
at Autodesk
people would say like why don't she
build meshmixer on top of something
because we had to do all the 3d stuff
ourselves and people had suggested this
and I was like that's never gonna work
that's a terrible idea
and then I left Autodesk and then I
built this thing on a game engine and it
really worked and so I was wrong and
then partly the reason I was wrong was
because like my concept of what a game
engine did was not really correct
anymore because when I was younger I had
done game type stuff and game engines
were much simpler than but now I mean
this is diagram it's sort of schematic
but if you actually were to look at like
the amount of code it's like game engine
is massive and I were just putting a
little bit on top the modern game
engines are crazy they do like all the
3d stuff for you they have amazing
rendering they can make like super
realistic looking stuff in real time
they have cool physics the really
amazing thing for me for or at first for
me was like you can put if you make a
thing in the game engine they can go on
any platform like if you wanted your CAD
tool and an Xbox you can do it and I
mean that sounds like nonsense the most
CAD people but like there's like
millions of kids who are 3d designers
now in Minecraft and like they use an
Xbox controller or a ps4 controller it's
like what would those kids do if we gave
them CAD tools and on a ps4 it would be
very cool
I think it has all support for all like
when now when people make a new input
device right away they have like api's
and the game engines it does the VR and
AR and it does all this real-time
network collaboration if you want to do
like remote stuff it's kind of crazy how
easy it is and these tools so if I was
thinking about this this whole time I
was doing these projects and it's not
really the totally the topic of this
talk but I thought I would just end with
it because I think a lot about like how
do we make software I mean I make a lot
of showed you like I've built myself
probably like six or seven different
quite large systems and I've been
involved in some other ones you know we
we had like pcs and we have these
operating systems for them and then we
got these phones these mobile devices
and we have these operating systems for
them and now we have these headsets we
wear around or could write I mean that's
the plan right we're all going to wear
around these AR glasses and we're gonna
do stuff in them right I mean that's the
theory at least we're not really
building it yet right VR mostly people
building or building games outside of
research labs and for these kind of
devices people are doing a bit more of
the AR goggles but they're not really
that ubiquitous yet but like almost
anytime you look at these projects
they're building them on one of these
game engines on like unreal or unity and
so those are kind of like the operating
system for these devices they have all
the stuff you need to make these things
and so for me that's really interesting
as a place to try and put this stuff
that I was thinking about and so yeah I
can't say what I'm going to work on in
the future but I mean that gives you a
bit of a hint and so that's my talk so
thank you I just want to tell you
there's code on github gradients base
ice I do lots of support on there if you
want to use any of the libraries you
have questions please don't hesitate
there's tutorials on the gradient-based
website also all my papers if you're
interested in the research side of this
stuff you can get at my website RMSA
decom and I tweet things on Twitter yeah
that's my talk thank you
you